[Music]
all right so when I say the word what
word happy we say birthday happy
birthday what about the United States of
America okay
what is the first word that comes to
mind hamburger oh yes the first word
that what Oh what's the first one that
comes to mind when you hear the word
ha America United yeah [ __ ] yeah america
[ __ ] yeah america [ __ ] yeah
Tron how does her trunk blue but Trump
hasn't always been America I know but
every like what he said was when I win
I'm thinking of cuz I'm in America so I
don't think of anything like that right
but like if I'm thinking from someone
outside of it that's true she is like
hamburger - mine's hamburger though he
embraces the hamburger so I feel like my
news to me picks up the past like for
years it's been Trump assed for years at
the Trump yeah yeah well there was a
survey done back in 2019 which is just
now being released so it took them a
year to kind of make sense of the survey
I guess Kuroda [ __ ] yeah they're
doing this the same people that are
doing the survey are interested in doing
it now to see kind of like what what the
survey would be now during the whole
coronavirus thing but they surveyed
specifically our neighbors Canadians and
Mexicans Canadians from Canada and
Mexicans in Mexico they're like when you
hear the word United States or America
what is the first thing that comes to
mind
Canadians it's stupid Mexico said
freedom oh that's not bad in a nutshell
three words and this is both of them
combined together Trump money and work
mmm there's the first three things that
come to mind is no [ __ ] or ya know I
feel like the money and work is Mexican
Trump is
yeah because they won't they're not they
have jobs they have other things that we
don't know but Trump is [ __ ] with
Mexicans too
he's try and fill the [ __ ] wall and
oh that's true oh yeah why you would
think wall what might be might be the
word that comes to I understand America
is money obsessed though it is just but
also I think it's also the immigrants
that come here that are like mighty
obsessed too like they're trying to make
it there's capitalism and people are
here to make it in life yeah making more
money in this for Mexicans when they
come here they're not trying to come
here to stay they come here to collect
what they can and they send it back home
yeah even when I talk to relatives in
like Vietnam and their idea of America
is wealth like that like they expected
when they get here that's what's gonna
be happening and then they go to
Hollywood to see all the land more the
land mines or whatever yeah landmarks
again it's all [ __ ] up they come to LA
and then there's a homeless person on
the corner but yeah so Canada in a
nutshell and specific Canada they they
use the words and these are all negative
words of course chaos confused bully
bully
okay well I think of Canada and say
afraid to speak their mind
I love Canadians I love Canada too yeah
and I think poutine poutine yes maple
syrup routine and kindness that's what I
really your ketchup chips though keep
them keep oh yeah
you know do be having here is if you
know the Canadian thing but the blaze
make that flavor
it's like lace chips with ketchup you
could get it here occasionally it just
tastes like ketchup trying to dip my
chips in some ketchup fries and ketchup
no man into chip I wouldn't say chips
taste like fries just think Lay's chips
with like ketchup powder on it no it's
it's just very Canadian if you want to
send us a sign oh yeah please send us
food we got some Canadian fans that
always send us care packages Oh marks
what the mask Mexico's do you think oh I
said money all right money more freedom
work and migration isn't the Mexican
dream like coming out here maybe raising
your family working and then going back
and retiring in Mexico because my
friends families did they did that they
opened up restaurants and whatever and
then their grandparents would go back
and you know live direct like a whole
ranch and [ __ ] you know
to be specific its migration not
immigration right Oh true yeah there's
so much that's we have so many Mexican
workers who come here to work for the
season and then go back true like so
many farmers are they just only coming
here for that farm season and that's it
and I could I would consider that more
of migration than immigration true yeah
true yeah I feel like they come here to
yeah just like you know birds there's
more opportunity yeah yeah for sure but
they also had the two words that ranked
really high two were negative words
what's discrimination yeah and racism
yeah something that Canada doesn't see
yeah obviously well it's white on white
Mexicans said that about the u.s. Oh
like in Mexico I want I mean what Asian
situation serious I don't know all right
because I feel like depending on the
country it's different cuz like Japan
might be like Hollywood cuz they're just
gonna come and visit right
depends a Jeff Japanese people are gonna
be like really happy and like they're
very like Japanese too they say yeah
they have their own money it's different
Japanese came here when they were poor
like around like back in a day when
they're a bunch of farmers that need it
work yeah you know and I think that's
what Mexico's going through like like
the the the difference in timeframe
because we've been going through that
[ __ ] well for Japan it it was like you
know the Industrial Revolution like when
that happened a lot of farmers didn't
get have jobs and [ __ ] so then they went
all over the world like Hawaii Brazil
and that's American gardeners yeah
sugarcane yeah so they weren't there
were migrant immigrants back then right
but then now I think they don't need it
same with Koreans like after the Korean
War they had to that there were like war
refugees and [ __ ] but now they don't
need it so like people that are coming
here it's I think they're just coming
here to like study abroad so different
experience from maybe people that are
running away from communism in China or
Vietnam or whatever you know yeah yeah
when I was reading this article like
something that came to mind was or like
I mean they even talked about it briefly
which was something that they found in
their survey was the fact that prior to
Trump's presidency you know when you
mentioned the word America or United
States many people would have a lot of
positive things to say and like a lot of
positivity to go with but you think
Obama's administration and people were
thinking like oh yeah that's great you
know like friendly helpful you know
whatever and then now that Trump is in
office the the PR of America has like
dipped quite a bit and so they're just
saying like this is quite a you know
it's the interesting time to be part of
this American like PR thing going that's
true yeah I mean the slogan of the
country has changed right before was
much more globalism right and now it's
like America first so the idea of
America and the way we interact with
people not necessarily even the actions
it's just the idea of the way America
interacting with people is completely
different sure yeah
to change the way you feel about
traveling internationally have you guys
travel internationally in the past four
years nobody counted
oh yeah and because of like Trump's
administration has it made you feel
different about being in international
countries I think I think that deep no
oh well I don't think I've just gone to
those countries that receive more of the
[ __ ] end of the stick
mmm whatever politician how they
interact with them right right
I've gone to Canada it's not that big of
a deal like they they bicker but it's
not like we're it's like oh yeah you
have to [ __ ] us up true and I think I
don't think when I say I don't think
that deep I'm obviously kidding but I
don't I don't think it ever crosses my
mind um just cuz I I don't fit the
American like stereotypical looks I
never feel any sort of backlash just
switch languages no they're mostly
looking at like the middle-aged like
white couple they look for I don't fit
the mold yeah they're just there that's
not our America you know true we don't
live we don't live amongst those types
of people I don't think in LA yeah but
if I thought was like blond hair blue
eyes I might have a difference but I do
see them like in Europe getting the
stink-eye or like because I don't think
when we're walking around they don't go
hi you dirty American I've ever seen
like foreign flicks like when they make
fun of Americans stereotypical look
America's Navy you told me about it I am
watching in bruises they just had a
scene where it was just uh basically the
guys were making fun of that Americans
they're like belly and like guys talk
like that I'd be like that they were
just fat white Americans and Tolan don't
walk upstairs because it's gonna be hard
for you guys like what do you mean he
goes okay you're fat and the guy went
like crazy and then he was like why
Americans will trigger so easily that's
pretty pretty accurate you know I think
I like when I see Americans are being
made fun of in foreign it's funny cuz
they get so mad but I'm like dude all we
do is make fun of other exactly it's
kind of like payback we ain't kind of
evens playing field but it's funny too
see how they see Americans we're like
they're like talking like this on
ourselves so bad yeah I saw this tweet
that was like pretty accurate where it
was like how we see Florida in America
and how like they do such thing so
stupid the rest of world sees we are
pretty [ __ ] dumb though dude like
just traveling abroad I'm just like man
some of these countries they're so
classy they're so intelligent they might
not have as much money but they just
know how to carry themselves like proper
ass people dress better I mean they
figure when they travel but not you
who's watching the video to me it's like
we have a cool experiment going on in
America with with so many different
cultures there's so many different types
of people trying to make it work and we
have so many it's just a bunch of like
difference difference like just trying
to make it work yeah we're like in
future clashes a lot yeah but if you go
to leave Japan or like Europe or
whatever you have guys that hat you you
had thousands of years to get it
together mainly one race yeah I thought
the I thought the percentage maybe yeah
I thought the percentage was like 98 our
Japanese and the rest is kind of mixed
in Japan and Iceland are like the two
countries that are still like majority
majority one race and so it's easier
when they all kind of think the same and
no one's really and it's a collectivist
society so I think even Europe - people
are more considerate because it's all
about that group mind and it's more
socialists out there but for us we have
that more like not individual yeah yeah
you're an individual so it's a
collective of individuals coming
together behind like America I look at
it's the United States right like every
state is so different from each I can be
its own country so you if you bring that
idea down to the individuals it's
exactly the same but you're a Behrman
you know like they respect so much of
their own individuality with everything
so I'm like yeah and plus we have 300
million people here like you know if you
look at just one European country it's
like yeah bro you're like one of our
state's
California has more people than one of
your countries I'm pretty stupid and I
like it
I like being stupid too
[Music]
[Music]
you